bonjour et bienvenue sur des gones lt
pour une émission tout à fait
inhabituelle aujourd'hui puisqu'on va
sortir de l'échiquier on va pas parler
de la riante on va pas parler de parties
d'échecs
on va pas interroger à un grand maître
international non non on va parler d'un
nouvel invité c'est le classement elo le
fameux classement elo comment fonctionne
le classement aux échecs ce fameux
classement you alors on va voir dans
cette émission plusieurs choses
intéressantes concernant ce classement
on va regarder tout de suite le menu bon
un petit historique d'abord sur son
fondateur arpad et l'eau puis ensuite on
verra que dans l'histoire du classement
et bien ça a changé il y avait d'abord
ce qu'on appelle une loi normale de
calcul et puis après on a une loi qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui logistique 1 fera un
petit topo là dessus assez rapide juste
que pour vous que vous ayez une petite
idée de ce dont il s'agit et savoir
qu'historiquement ça donc changé que
lots avaient proposé une loi normale et
qu'on l'a un peu modifié pour une
fonction qui finalement plus simple mais
qui change pas grand chose à ce qu'avait
fait le fondateur et ensuite on verra
comment calculer le gain en fonction du
vélo et votre calcul de points comment
vous pouvez calculer des points à partir
de la fonction vous allez voir c'est
finalement in fine est assez simple on
verra des cas pratiques concrets et vous
pourrez avec une simple calcul est
calculée après partie après partie et
bien les points que vous gagnez que vous
perdez en fonction de votre résultat est
en fonction de votre classement donc
lots et celui de votre adversaire et
enfin le verra à des statistiques très
intéressantes sur l'ensemble des joueurs
classés par la fidh et on verra
plusieurs pays comment les joueurs sont
distribués c'est à dire quelqu'un comme
il ya deux joueurs par tranche de points
elo est aussi on verra comment les les
grands maîtres internationaux sont
distribués comment les maîtres
internationaux sont distribués dans ce
classement elo avec des graphiques où on
apprendra beaucoup de choses
intéressantes donc premiers points et un
peu d'historique pour parler donc de
notre ami arpad lots fondateur du
classement donc il est né en 1903 il est
mort en 1992
aux etats unis c'est un scientifique et
un mathématicien il avait aussi
d'ailleurs proposé ce classement elo à
la fédération de tennis qui n'en
revenant pas voulu
aujourd'hui que le tennis et le
classement qu'on appelle atp association
of tennisman professionnel simple
association des tennismen professionnels
eh bien ils en ont pas voulu c'est le
jeu d'échecs qu'il a choisi alors c'est
pas très étonnant puisque jeu d'échec on
s'est calé il a une dimension
scientifique
on le sait d'ailleurs depuis le xviiie
siècle dans la préface du fameux
philidor l'analyse du jeu d'échecs de
philidor que vous connaissez un peu
maintenant si vous suivez des gones ltv
avec sa réédition récente est bien le
grand mathématicien les venir lui-même
dans cette préface bien estime que le
jeu d'échecs est tout à fait
scientifique il faut l'approcher de
façon scientifique donc c'est pas très
étonnant qu'un classement extrêmement
pointus mathématiques tels que le
classement elo et été adopté par les
joueurs d'échecs alors en quoi ça
consiste exactement
eh bien il s'agit avec le classement elo
d'avoir un classement un nombre de
points qui fait que quand compte quand
on connait la différence de points donc
c'est ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
différence de points
la différence entre deux joueurs par
exemple un joueur classé 1800 lots et
inclut un joueur classé 2000 et l'eau ce
qui nous intéresse c'est qu'ils ont une
différence de classement de 200 points
et bien en fonction de cette différence
de classement on saura en mesure de
calculer la probabilité de gain de l'un
sur l'autre
donc si vous voulez s'ils vont faire par
exemple 60 % de gain l'un sur l'autre
eh bien on s'attend s'ils jouent du
parti y en ait un qui gagne 6 points et
l'autre seul seulement 4 et bien le
classement nous permet de faire ça voilà
donc c'est un classement qui est
extrêmement intéressant puisqu'il nous
donne immédiatement un rapport de force
calculable voilà il s'assied une grande
nouveauté c'est la grande originalité
proposé par ares pas des lots et jusqu'à
jusqu'à lui on n'avait jamais pensé à
faire un classement de cette forme là à
noter que le classement elo aujourd'hui
est adoptée dans quantité d'autres jeux
que ce soit le go ou d'autres jeux et y
compris sur des jeux
on s'attend pas à le trouver notamment
sur internet beaucoup de deux sites de
classement en ligne utilisent le
classement elo avec bonheur tout le
monde on est très content parce que ça
marche très très bien
alors qu'est ce que la loi normale alors
c'est une fonction qui a cette tête là
je vous fais pas le détail c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi la loi des grands
nombres bon si ça vous intéresse faut
faire des maths
il faut étudier l'histoire de ça on va
pas à étudier cette fonction en détail
simplement on verra quand même
graphiquement à quoi ça ressemble c'est
la loi normale
alors et alors faut savoir que donc ça a
changé ça a été modifiée au cours du
temps donc au départ c'est bien cette
loi là qui étaient utilisés tel que
proposé par lots arpad lots donc le
mathématicien fondateur du classement et
maintenant on utilise une loi qui
s'appelle logistique et qui à cette
forme là mais vous allez voir quand
pratiques sont très proches les deux
vous allez voir qu'en fait il n'y a pas
de grande différence
si ce n'est peut-être que d'ailleurs
cette loi logistique et plus simple à
calculer que celle là ça en pratique
vous allez voir que le calcul et in fine
est assez simple c'est pas très très
compliqué et on peut calculer son
classement presque à la main il faut
quand même une petite calculatrice parce
qu'une petite fonction un tout petit peu
compliqué mais pas tant que ça et on va
comparer les deux aussi voilà alors on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble voilà la loi
normale donc vous voyez c'est une courbe
en cloche tout à fait le standard alors
ça veut dire quoi en fait ça veut dire
qu'on s'attend à ce que les joueurs
soient répartis si vous voulez selon
cette répartition là alors c'est ce
qu'on verra on verra si les joueurs
fidèles sont bien réparties selon ce
type de fonction on va voir ça alors ça
c'est la loi normale elle regardait la
loi logistique vous allez voir n'allez
pas vous allez être un peu déçu c'est la
même
voilà elle est juste un tout petit peu
plus comprimé au centre mais en gros
vous voyez bien que la différence est
très faible on peut même comparer les
deux alors si vous le faites à la main
attention parce que il faut normaliser
les variances ça veut dire qu'en fait
bon et petits paramètres qu'il faut
juste faire un peu attention pour qu'on
puisse les comparer et les mettre sur le
même le même graphique mais grosso modo
ça donne ça voyez que à peu près c'est à
peu près les mêmes en bleu on voit la
normale et dessus la loi logistique
voyez bon la différence elle est
vraiment
c'est vraiment à la limite simplement
effectivement il ya un petit tassement
au centre bon enfin plus de plus de
rouge au centre dans la logistique et
plus aigus ici et un peu moins sur les
côtés bon ça fait pas une différence
très très notable c'est pas très
intéressant alors maintenant on va voir
comment calculer la probabilité de gain
en fonction du vélo ou alors ça c'est
intéressant alors la logistique tel
qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure on avait sa
densité de probabilités mais ça ça vous
intéresse pas trop ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir calculer donc le pourcentage de
gains en fonction de la différence de
classement alors la différence de
classement dans cette formule est ici on
l'appelle grande et facile d par exemple
je suis classé 1800 lots l'adversaire
est classé 2000 et au et bien la
différence ce sera mis en deux cent
mille huit cent moins de 1000 ça fait un
nombre négatif ça sera moins de 100 il
faut remplacer dans cette formule des
parts moins de 100 alors fake c'est
assez simple final c'est un / 1 + 10
puissance moins il ya un signe moins
l'intention ici la différence de
placement / 400 donc ça veut dire quand
et différence de classement de 400
points elo fait que ce petit rapport la
dea sur 400 vaudra 1
on va en parler juste ici exemple de
calcul donc
imaginons deux joueurs qui ont 400
points de différence donc par exemple un
joueur qui à 2000 joue face à un joueur
qui à 2400 donc celui qui à 2400 pour
lui la différence avec l'autre joueur
c'est 400 points il regarde sa
probabilité de gain il faut donc
calculer 1 / 1 + 10 puissance moins 400
sur 400 m et 4 cents soit 4 cents ça
fait 1 donc ça fait 1 sur 1 + 10
puissance moins il ya un signe - il faut
pas l'oublier ici dix puissance moins
les uns c'est quoi baisse et 0,1
le calcul ça donne finalement 1 / 1,1
moyens aériennes plus simple quand même
c'est extrêmement simple et au final ça
lui donne 90 % de chances
voilà alors si on avait calculé depuis
celui qui avait deux mille lots lui 2000
moins de 1400 alors eu moins 400 ici on
fait le même calcul - f et moins ça
donnerait plus donc s'attendre à un / 1
+ 10 puissance 1
donc ça ferait 1 sur 11 et on
calculerait ça ferait quasiment 10%
c'est à dire ici ce qui manque à 90 pour
atteindre 100 c'est normal s'il à 90% de
chances de gain il faut s'attendre à ce
que l'autre est simplement 10 1 voilà
donc ses fonctions d ont des propriétés
bien entendu de symétrie si la
différence de classement entre deux
joueurs par exemple de jour 1800 l'un et
1800 l'autre 1800 aussi donc ça fait
zéro quelle est la probabilité est bien
on fait le calcul
1 / 1 + 10 puissance moins 0 sur 4 100 0
/ quelque chose ça fait toujours zéro le
moins ça tout ça je trouve pas non plus
donc ça fait 1 / 1 + 10 puissance 0 10
puissance 0 c'est un toutou nombre à la
puissance 0 fait toujours un sa seule
vous avez dû l'apprendre en
mathématiques ou si vous n'avez pas pris
je vous l'apprends donc ça fait 1 / en
plusieurs c'est à dire 2 et on obtient
bien 50% ouf on s'attend quand même et
sur ceux ci la différence de classement
et de zéro à ce que ça soit 50%
bon alors voyez que 400 ça nous donne un
nombre facile à calculer et 0 aussi bon
c'est un peu plus compliqué dès que la
différence est pas aussi simple
alors notamment avec 100 regardons entre
- s'en ressent alors on verra que ces
deux nombres la deux la somme fait bien
s'en est bien dix puissance moins -
censure 400 quand y'a moins et moins ça
fait plus sens sur 400 sa fille en
quarts donc ça fait 1 / 1 + 10 puissance
un quart alors ça vous pouvez pas le
calcul et de tête personne peut le faire
il vous faut une calculatrice là pour
faire 10 puissance un quart un quartier
aussi 0.25 vous faites 10 puissance 0.25
et vous obtiendrez donc 1 / 1 + 1,770
vous pouvez vous arrêter à trois
chiffres
ça suffit largement et on obtient 36%
donc si vous avez 100 points de moins
que votre adversaire
attendez-vous à faire 36 % des points en
moyenne
voilà si vous fait donc 20 parties
contre des joueurs classés 100 points de
plus que vous attendez vous à faire 36 %
des points c'est à dire moins de huit
points sur 20 par exemple
voilà si on veut un parti ça fera moins
neuf moins de huit points
et si vous avez 100 points de plus et
bien vous refaites le calcul miracles ça
fait bien le complémentaire de 36 à fait
bien 64% 64 et 36 ça fait bien 100 %
heureusement donc
amusez-vous à faire ses calculs pour
n'importe quelle différence de points et
vous aurez le pourcentage
bon très bien maintenant regardons à
quoi ressemble cette fonction qui n'est
pas la fonction de répartition logis ses
fins de densité qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure c'est la fonction de point les
50% sont atteints ici pour le zéro le
zéro et là ici donc cette barre
correspond à 50% est évidemment plus
vous avez des quarts avec l'adversaire
plus vous tendez vers 100 % de
possibilité d'envoyer la courbe elle
fait ça voilà donc ici ça veut dire quoi
se dire vous un classement très négatif
par rapport à l'adversaire ça veut dire
que vous êtes très en dessous de
l'adversaire et donc votre probabilité
de temps vers zéro exemple vous jouez
contre le cas un joueur qui a plus de
500 points que vous bien on s'attend ce
que vous perdiez la partie quasiment à
chaque fois alors en pratique comment
calcul des points parce que c'est bien
là on a calculé la probabilité de game
nous en pratique ce qu'on veut faire si
je vais jouer une partie bon comment je
peux savoir combien de poids je vais
gagner où je vais perdre alors le
classement il suit la règle suivante
votre ancien classement c'est votre lots
à l'étape précédente lots de l est le
nouveau classement ces lots n + 1 alors
le n plusieurs ça sera le lots précédant
plus cette petite formule un c'est très
simple car c'est un facteur qui lui est
pas lié à la formule qu'on a vu là ils
vont soit 40 pour un nouveau joueur soit
20 pour un joueur confirmé c'est à dire
qu'il a joué qu'un joueur qui a joué
plus de 30 parties et enfin 10 pour les
joueurs dont le vélo est supérieur à
2400 en général c'est des joueurs qui
ont joué plus de 30 partis on a theme
pas de 1400 par hasard comme ça quand on
vient d'arriver
c'est il faut ils font peu de temps même
même pour les jeunes donc c'est un peu
long donc 40 20 ou 10 voilà en gros vous
avez les
ces coefficients donc pour la majorité
des joueurs ça sera vain parce que si
vous suivez ce cette émission est bien
probablement vous êtes un joueur qui a
déjà un classement elo donc votre
placement sera probablement vains si
vous êtes un grand maître vous
connaissez le classement ne faisait pas
besoin de ce que je vous de ce que je
vous explique
et si alors vous pouvez aussi être un
nouveau joueur qui a envie de jouer des
tournois dans ce cas là vous aurez un
cas qui vaut 40 tant que vous n'avez pas
joué 30 parties officielles
bon donc ça c'est un coefficient qui est
pas très très intéressant pour le calcul
ils ont théorique enfin il faut le
connaître mais c'est pas c'est pas
difficile il est donné par la fidh et on
peut pas le deviner celui là et ici ce
coefficient x quoi par le résultat que
vous allez faire
mais le résultat attendu c'est à dire la
fameuse probabilité de gain qui dépend
de la différence entre votre classement
et celui de l'adversaire d'accord donc
par exemple si votre différence de
classement c'est zéro on a vu que le
classe à cette fonction faudra 50 %
c'est-à-dire 0.5 donc le résultat
attendu c'est 0,5 si vous faites 05 - 05
safra 0 et votre classement il bougera
pas le nouveau autres galles à
l'ancienne plus qu'à fois zéro c'est à
dire 0
ça changera pas donc il ne changera que
si votre résultat est supérieur d'accord
enfin trouvé une augmentera que si votre
résultat est supérieur au résultat
théorique et il baissera si votre
résultat est inférieur aux résultats
théoriques
voilà voilà le principe déjà de base
exemple avec le calcul imaginons un
joueur confirmé qu'à sera égal à 20 il a
joué plus de 30 parties il est assez
1900 et l'eau il affronte un joueur qui
est classée 2100 et l'eau et se joue en
1900 il va gagner la partie donc le
résultat c'est un la différence du
classement vous d égale 1900 - 2005
c'est à dire moins de 100 points
ça veut dire le d ici le dès qu'on a vu
dans la fonction au dessus qu'on va
revoir ici moins de 100 points donc il
faut calculer l'espérance de gain
théorique selon donc notre ami arpad
lots donc la fonction logistique cf2
moins de sens puisque on a moins de 100
points
il faut faire 1-1 / 1 + 10 puissance
moins moins de 100 sur 400 ont moins en
moins attention ça fera plus
200 sur 400 ça fait un demi c'est facile
1 / 1 + 10 puissance 1/2 puissance
ennemie ça va dit c'est pareil que la
racine carrée mais peu importe sur la
calculatrice vous faites 10 puissance
0.5 et vous obtiendrez 3.162 et des
poussières
et quand vous faites la différence enfin
le le ratio de 1 / 1 + 3 6 2 c'est à
dire 10 puissance ennemie
eh bien vous obtiendrez 24 % de chance
c'est normal il à 200 points de plus que
vous théoriquement s'attend à ce que
vous ne gagnez que 24% des points c'est
à dire pas grand chose et vous avez
gagné donc vous avez sans doute gagné
beaucoup de points elo et lui et va en
perdre il perdra ce que vous gagnez bien
sûr c'est ça le principe et le calcul ça
sera donc que le nouveau classement sera
égal à l'ancien classement plus car il
ya le vin foie heures vous avez gagné ne
le gain théorique on s'attend à ce que
vous fassiez 24 % dont un - 24 %
c'est-à-dire 1 - 08 24 24% c'est aussi
24 / son il suffit de faire calcul 20
fois un -24% poule faire de tête ou au
parc avec la calculatrice encore mieux
et vous obtenez 15,2 voilà donc où
autrement dit si vous gagnez la partie
face à un joueur qui a 200 points de
plus que vous vous gagnez d'un coup bon
15,2 points elo voilà et vous pouvez
faire ce calcul pour toutes les
différences de poids que vous voulez
voyez c'est pas très très compliqué
voilà la théorie dans land vous avez
tous les outils maintenant avec cette
fonction est envoyée cas assez simple au
final et cette fameuse ce fameux calcul
pour calculer les points
maintenant on a vu cette histoire de
probabilités de répartition on va enfin
voir des choses aussi tout à fait
intéressante
comment les joueurs classés et le haut
par la fidh et sont répartis par classe
mal ou pas rien quelle est la moyenne
quel et comment ils sont classés alors
voilà ici un petit schéma on va le voir
de plus près voilà
voilà le graphique 2015
ici de la répartition des joueurs
internationaux par la fidh est alors
attention
la fidh et qu'on te pas tous les joueurs
il ya des joueurs qui sont encore
classés par les fédérations nationales
et pas encore par la fidh mais depuis
quelques années la fidh et en intégrer
tous les joueurs dans son classement
donc regarder on retrouve bien notre
courbe en cloche
alors elle est quand même particulière
comme on le voit ici on a quand même
beaucoup en plus ici de joueurs que
devant en théorie ça devrait être
équilibré alors il ya des raisons à ça
c'est que historiquement on ne classe et
que les joueurs au niveau international
supérieur à 2200 points et loup avant on
avait que ça on n'avait pas du tout les
joueurs avant donc du coup le temps que
les nouveaux classé rencontre les
anciens classé et que tout ça se tasse
il va se passer du temps ça c'est un
premier point puis plus tard dans le
temps c'était plus de 1200 la limite
d'entrer dans le classement
international s'est passé à 2000 donc on
se retrouve à 2 min 6 avec un pic
on a un petit pic lac est pas tout à
fait normal si on avait une belle loi
statistique mais c'est dû au fait que le
2200 avant ils étaient ils étaient là le
pic on avait un pic à 2200 maintenant il
est passé à 2000 pareil donc c'est dû au
fait qu'on a intégré mêlant des nouveaux
joueurs qui ont pas eu le temps encore
de faire suffisamment de partie face
donc aux joueurs qui sont là depuis plus
longtemps dans classement international
donc il ya une petite discontinuité mais
c'est dû à des raisons essentiellement
historique sinon à part ça on a bien une
belle courbe logistique à peu près si
vous voulez passer alors à noter qu'il
ya 200 4779 joueurs classés ce qui est
quand même pas mal
alors il ya des actifs et des non actifs
sains ils sont pas forcément tous actifs
donc on va voir maintenant d'autres
éléments intéressants alors la moyenne
ici comme elle sait que c'est
intéressant à noter que la moyenne se
trouve maintenant aux alentours de 1950
voilà 1950-2000 la moyenne des joueurs
internationaux le c'est à dire le sommet
de notre courbe ici un se retrouve aux
alentours de 1900 parle à peu près mille
neuf cent pas fait la moyenne exactes
sur tout ça va changer un petit peu dans
le temps année après année mais en gros
aujourd'hui c'est aux alentours de 1900
ici on a donc les débutants qui débute à
1000 lots 1
voilà les joueurs les plus bas classés
sont aux alentours de 1000 euros et ça
monte progressivement puis ça redescend
progressivement à noter ici qu'on voit
pas du tout les tout meilleurs mondiaux
parce que ici on a quand même une
hauteur ici à 14000 points enfin 14
mille joueurs ici au top entre 12 et 14
mille joueurs ici et on est par tranche
de 50 points et l'on voit là c'est à
dire qu'en bas chaque chaque baril ci
représente le nombre de joueurs par
exemple ici pour 7 pour cette barre l'a
vraiment qui est vraiment au milieu qui
sont placés entre 1900 et 1950
donc il y en a environ 13000 voilà il y
en a treize mille pour ceux qui sont
entre 1850 et 9900 est aussi et 13000
entre 1950 et 2000 voilà tout ça c'est
aux alentours de 13 mille voyez donc on
a une belle courbe logistique
voilà alors maintenant alors c'est les
mêmes abscisse en bas j'ai rien changé
pour l' axe du bape de façon à ce qu'on
puisse y voir clair regarder la
précédente et regarder la nouvelle
on est toujours entre 1000 et 3000
évidemment ici par contre l'échelle et
pas du tout la même on a ici le nombre
de grands maîtres internationaux qui
sont classés par tranche de 50 points
alors oui c'est très intéressant c'est
aussi on voit bien une courbe logistique
alors pour qu'elles soient plus fine
il aurait fallu que je change je ne vais
pas faire de 50 ans 50 mais de 10 ans 10
mais bon ce pas très intéressant à faire
évidemment alors moins les joueurs sont
nombreux et plus la courbe semble
sur resserré vers le centre c'est normal
c'est la canal + il ya environ mille
quatre cent soixante dix neuf donc
grands maîtres internationaux classée
donc environ 1490 1500 alors il y en a
des actifs et des non actifs là aussi
moi j'ai pris la liste complète un donné
par la fille des déclassements j'ai pas
vérifié s'ils étaient actifs ou pas mais
ça me donne une bonne idée du nombre de
grands maîtres active dans le monde
quand même 1480 voilà classé en tout cas
ceux qui sont classés et la moyenne
alors ça c'est très intéressant à noter
la moyenne sur le pic
parce que quand on a vu la loi n
logistique et un pic au niveau de la
moyenne en fait la moyenne des joueurs
grands maîtres elle est aux alentours de
2500 points
bonds est à noter que cette moyenne
c'est exactement la moyenne historique
c'est à dire celle qui a été décidée
quand on a initialisé le classement en
1970 ou fischer
bobby fischer a été le premier à avoir
le lead le leader à être le leader du
classement elo internationale lors du
premier classement en 1970 il était déjà
devant spassky avant même de gagner le
championnat du monde
et bien cette moyenne et l'ol n'a pas
bougé ça veut dire que si vous voulez
n'y a pas d'inflation du tout du
classement faut pas oublier ce que c'est
c'est une loi de probabilité sert plus
je mettrais de grand maître
c'est plus j'aurai deux grands maîtres
demain imaginons que beaucoup plus de
gens se mettent à jouer aux échecs on
aura plus de grands maîtres c'est
mécanique
si toute la plaine se met à jouer aux
échecs il y aura pas 1500 grand maître
il y en aura beaucoup plus bon on peut
supposer que ça sera pas le cas on va
pas faire que jouer aux échecs il faut
qu'on fasse d'autres choses aussi
mais évidemment plus on mettra toujours
plus aura de grands maîtres et puis on a
de grands maîtres plus la courbe ira sur
les côtés forcément
donc si vous voulez c'est pas une
inflation du nombre de points elo qui a
c'est une inflation du nombre de joueurs
il ya plus de grands maîtres aujourd'hui
qui en avait avant mais la moyenne est
l'eau des grands maîtres est la même
pourquoi on a les grands maîtres à moins
de 1000 de 2500 élevé c'est normal parce
que la règle si vous voulez c'est quand
on atteint 2500 lots et qu'on a fait les
normes de grand maître
il faut avoir atteint deux mille cinq
cents lots au moins une fois on obtient
le titre à vie bon mais c'est pas parce
qu on l'atteint qu'on va aller après au
delà on
bien sûr redescendre vous avez fait
l'expérience d'avoir une classement et
oh c'est pas parce que vous avez atteint
un certain niveau que vous êtes
forcément conviés à aller plus haut vous
pouvez aussi avoir touché votre maximum
et ensuite redescendre donc c'est normal
qu'ils aient des grands maîtres qui sont
en dessous de 2500 et d'autres qui
soient au dessus
normalement il devrait y en avoir
d'ailleurs autant plus bas que plus haut
on voit que ici grosso modo cet
équilibre et c'est à peu près équilibré
et on a une belle courbe logistique dont
il n'y a pas d'inflation de points l'eau
c'est une c'est une erreur statistique
de dire ça et à une inflation il ya plus
de joueurs mais la moyenne des grands
maîtres vaut toujours 2500 et c'est ça
qui compte
alors suivant maintenant les maîtres
internationaux ça c'est intéressant
eh bien regardez alors la courbe est un
peu différente
on a quand même une loi logistique ici
on la voit alors par contre la
différence c'est que la moyenne est bien
sûr plus basse et on a toujours une
moyenne ici la moyenne est sans doute
entre ces deux pics et ses deux pics et
entre 2350 et 2450 donc c'est bien aux
alentours de 2400 points elo voilà et
bien pour être maître international il
faut atteindre 2400 points elo c'est pas
très étonnant non plus que l'appareil a
pas d'inflation par contre y'a plus de m
vous voyez qu'il y avait 1500 environ
quand m là on est à 3400 m voilà 1482
remmetre exactement 1479 est ici 3401
maîtres internationaux dans le monde
voilà donc et ne avec une moyenne et
l'eau toujours admis 400 points et une
loi de logistique
voilà alors comme ils sont pas très
nombreux éléments par rapport aux 204
mille joueurs classés dans le monde
eh bien oui bien entendu la loi
logistique allait elle apparaît peu
parce que là j'ai en plus pris un pas de
50 points lors si je prenais même pas
plus plus petit de 10 points elo par
exemple jeu vers une courbe un peu plus
lisse un bien sûr là c'est parce que mon
g
j'ai pris les 50 points en 50 points
donc c'est un peu plus un peu plus
tronçonné si vous voulez un visuel alors
ça c'est très intéressant maintenant on
va voir quelques fédérations
là aussi on apprend beaucoup de choses
il ya 14 1717 français classé
internationaux au classement 14 1717
alors regarder la courbe alors c'est une
logistique on voit bien à peu près 1
mais alors vraiment faut quand même la
chercher parce que vous voyez bon il ya
quand même un pic avec une montée à
gauche une descente à droite à noter
qu'ici on a un décrochage
bon eh bien c'est aux alentours de 2000
donc scellier pareil au fait qu' il ya
dès maintenant la fidh et intègre les
moins de 2000 donc forcément on a on a
ici un afflux de nouveaux joueurs qui
jusqu'ici
n'entrez pas dans le classement
international donc ça va ce lycée au
cours du temps c'est pas quelque chose
qui va durer ça gère d'ici quelques
années
théoriquement ce truc là devrait ce
lycée ça peut prendre beaucoup de temps
ça peut prendre dix ans ça va pas
forcément se faire à six mois il faut le
temps que les parties se fasse et que
tout ça se tasse à noter que la moyenne
semble se positionner à ses alentours là
ici voilà donc c'est à dire aux
alentours de pour la france donc ça
c'est intéressant à noter 1700 lots
voilà entre 1700 et 1750 et le hall à la
moyenne des joueurs classés français
pour 14 1717 classés français intéressés
à savoir pour la france les russes mais
c'est intéressant la russie j'ai pris
quelques fédérations intéressante alors
ils sont plus nombreux ils sont pas
14700 ils sont vingt 1276 donc plutôt
20000 donc voilà ça fait beaucoup plus
pareil on voit bien ici une montée avec
une chute ici pareil parce que toujours
pareil la fidh et vient d'intégrer ces
nouveaux joueurs et c'est bien aux
alentours de 2000 que ça se passe 7,7
ici on voit bien qu'il ya un décrochage
ici là et puis un deuxième par la sas et
l'ancien l'ancien décrochage on est à
2002 il a c'est le nouveau à 2000 donc
un premier décrochage un des décrochages
ça va se lisser dans le temps qu'ils
sont quand même beaucoup plus nombreux
c'est la fédération la plus nombreuse où
ils sont les plus nombreux
et la moyenne et l'eau des russes est
plus forte que les français français
dont 1700 là on est plutôt aux alentours
de en termes de moyenne quelque chose
qui doit tourner autour de 2050
voilà 2050 lots pour le russe donc ils
sont quand même 300 points au dessus des
français ils sont plus forts mais ça on
le savait en moyenne 1 mais sur en
moyenne les américains alors les
américains première chose à noter ils
sont pas nombreux du tout 3800 joueurs
c'est vraiment peu quand on voit le
nombre de joueurs classés ne serait-ce
que français alors que les américains
sont plus nombreux en terme de
population générale mais en tant que
joueur d'échecs classé fidesz et pas
beaucoup alors 3809 américain seulement
c'est pas énorme donc ça fait ça fait
une logistique plus ramassé puisque
voyez que la faim ici l'échelle est plus
petite et la moyenne et l'eau des
américains et aux alentours par contre
ici on voit bien de 2050 points voilà
c'est aussi aux alentours de ce pic là
que ça se passe de 1050 points donc
c'est plutôt une fédération où la
moyenne approche celle des russes mais
avait beaucoup moins de joueurs
donc si l afflux vous imaginez la
situation
c'est exactement ça qui s'est passé pour
les autres fédérations si vous avez un
afflux de nouveaux américains qui vont
arriver
imaginons qu'il soit 15000 mais ça veut
dire qu'il y en aurait presque douze
mille de plus ou onze mille de plus
puisque ce sont pas loin de 4 mais ici
imaginez onze mille nouveaux américains
qui arrivent d'un coup ça sera pas des
joueurs qui sont du côté fort ici ça
sera des joueurs plutôt débutants plutôt
des joueurs de clubs de niveau je dirais
standards français donc ça ferait
baisser un peu leur moyenne vers la
gauche
voilà salaire au lieu d'être à 2052
moyen de joueurs classés sans doute sa
descendre et vers les mille neuf cent
mille huit cents voire moins voilà donc
c'est difficile à savoir
tant que ces joueurs sont pas intégrés
bon faut savoir aussi que depuis
longtemps la fédération américaine mais
c'est vrai parce que pour le classement
elo c'est vrai pour beaucoup de choses
aux états unis qui sont quand même assez
protectionnistes et ils ont leur propre
classement à eux
pas forcément envie de donner des sous à
la fédération internationale pour
intégrer leurs joueurs au classement fis
d2 ça viendra sans doute ensuite
l'allemagne très intéressant l'allemagne
aussi puisqu'ils sont extrêmement
nombreux regarder presque vingt mille
comme les russes disent 9302 donc plus
que les français pas beaucoup plus en
proportion de la population il ya 80
millions d'habitants en allemagne contre
64 millions en france donc c'est pas
c'est à peu près pareil en proportion la
population qu'en france par contre au
niveau on regarder la courbe on il ya
toujours cette chute ici à 2000 et à
2002 donc dû à l'historique a encore une
fois je le rappelle avant c'était que
les au dessus de 2002 qui était classé
internationaux puis c'est passé à 2000
est maintenant seul seulement depuis
quelques années à peine 1 4 4 5 ans
peut-être un peu plus mais quelques
années la fidh et commencent à intégrer
les joueurs de tous niveaux jusqu'à 1000
points et gowalla et bien mise à part
cette remarque qui revient souvent et
bien la moyenne et l'eau des allemands
est intéressante à connaître donc elle
correspond à ce pic ici bien sûr c'est
la loi la logistique donc la moyenne est
centrée et c'est aux alentours de 2000
et l'eau voilà donc voilà un pays qui en
termes de moyenne rejoint les russes à
la fois en termes de oc de quantité et
de moyenne se situe très forte nation
une chicken les anglais alors pareil que
les américaines sont pas nombreux 2377
anglais classé fi des voiliers donc là
aussi long au classement a eu assez du
sud même pas si c'est pas spécial leur
classement anglais on peut importe donc
ils ont pas forcément pris l'habitude ou
l'envi où ils n'ont pas eu envie de
de s'intégrer au classement
international donc ils sont dans une
situation de joueurs internationaux
pas très nombreux et donc on retrouve
donc toujours se sentent rage avec une
loi un peu tronqué quand même il ya plus
de nouveaux joueurs quand même on voit
bien un afflux à gauche par rapport à ce
qui est à droite c'est pas symétrique
donc ça c'est parce qu'il ya un afflux
de nouveaux joueurs et la moyenne est
aux alentours de 2000 2050
bon c'est pas significatif c'est comme
les américains puisqu'ils sont pas aussi
nombreux qu'on pourrait s'attendre à ce
qu'il soit en proportion de leur
population
les espagnols en espagne aussi
intéressantes sont seize 1186 c'est à
dire plus nombreux que les français
alors que l'espagne est un pays moins
peuplés que la france la faune espagne
c'est 40 5 millions nous 64 millions en
france
donc s'ils sont plus nombreux classé
fidh et en espagne c'est que bien
entendu l'aficion l'aficion par l'art et
l'art quel est l'intérêt pour le jeu
d'échecs en espagne est beaucoup plus
grand qu'en france il
il ya un historique plus long plus large
vous savez que le jeu d'échecs est
arrivé en europe notamment via l'espagne
suite à la conquête et bien
les arabes en espagne vers le 12ème
13ème siècle 14e siècle par là et que
c'est
c'est suite à cette ce mélange qui a eu
en espagne et bien que le jeu d'échecs
est passé en europe et donc en espagne
que et dans la péninsule ibérique en
général au portugal aussi et damiano
henri lopès que l'on retrouve
eh bien les premiers traités historiques
du jeu 16 8 186 espagnols eux classés et
depuis apparemment assez longtemps et
regarder avec une grosse activité parce
que on voit bien que la courbe ellis
donc ça c'est ça c'est important à
comprendre c'est que si la courbe ellis
qu'ils ont eu le temps de mélanger les
joueurs beaucoup donc qu'ils ont joué
beaucoup de parties donc à plus de
tournois internationaux en espagne que
sans doute dans les autres pays
oui vous voyez on apprend beaucoup de
choses d'un coup d'oeil sur une sur une
courbe à noter que la moyenne et l'eau
par contre est assez proche de la
moyenne française c'est aux alentours de
1800 c'est par là un donc c'est entre
1800 1850
voilà il ya un petit pic ici mais il ya
un peu plus de barre à droite donc on
sait par là c'est à peu près pareil
qu'en france à 50 points elo s'est pas
non plus énorme
mais bon en terme de moyenne ça fait ça
fait quand même quelque chose de
significatif voilà donc en tout cas on
voit à la fête que la courbe est lisse
et quelles réelles épouse vraiment bien
une courbe logistique
voyez en pratique que eh bien il joue
beaucoup plus en espagne ils ont le
temps de l'iss et l'intégration des
nouveaux joueurs beaucoup plus
rapidement que dans les autres pays
enfin une fédération que j'ai trouvé
très intéressante a noté pascal est
vraiment particulier en termes de
regarder de répartition c'est l'inde
l'inde regarde et dit 7316 indien
classés et une courbe étonnante très
étonnant pour lé elle regarde et
puisqu'on a une moyenné l'eau qui se
tasse ici c'est à dire on a
essentiellement quoi une moyenne aux
alentours de 1350 points
voilà ce qui est un niveau on le sait
deux joueurs qui commencent à savoir
bien jouer un joueur de club qui
commence à connaître
et bien un peu tout ce qu'il faut savoir
pour jouer une partie tout à fait
correct 1400 points c'est quelqu'un qui
voilà qui peut jouer aux échecs sans
plus besoin de demander conseil
en tout cas pour finir la partie et pour
savoir comment finir mater etc voilà bon
donc ça veut dire quoi cette courbe mais
ça veut dire que les indiens démarre en
fait ça veut dire que les indiens ça
fait peu de temps que l'inde s'est mis à
jouer aux échecs de façon importante et
c'est sans doute bien entendu suite au
parcours extraordinaire de vichy en inde
au championnat du monde et aussi bien
entendu de impy conejo puisque donc avec
un pic au niveau fichier non disons en
n2 fer de lance exceptionnel bien
entendu fiche à nantes ça fait quand
même des années bien sûr qu'il est sur
le circuit international mais son titre
de champion du monde en a fait une méga
star en inde est forcément à susciter
des vocations
l'un de mes ruches aux échecs on peut
dire puisque si on remonte l'histoire là
aussi l'inde a probablement été un des
terreaux où le terreau même l'endroit où
le jeu d'échecs a été mis au point il ya
près plus de 1500 ans de ça avec son
ancêtre le chat tu rends gars comme nous
l'expliquent nicolas giffard dans son
anthologie le guide des échecs sont
traités qui comporte une partie
historique remarquable
et bien voilà l'aisne se remet à jour
déchets mille cinq cents ans plus tard
avec l'arrivée d'anand de l'arrivée chez
les filles de m piccone rossi qui est
numéro deux mondial je crois bien
derrière les diffamer ou la chinoise
voilà et donc sur ce graphique on voit
tout de suite on voit tout de suite
l'arrivée massive de ces nouveaux
joueurs avec ce pic ici ce nombre de
joueurs classés à 1400 qui veut dire que
c'est une fédération qui débute dans la
sidération qui rejouent qui tue vos
échecs depuis pas longtemps en terme de
quantité de joueurs avec une arrivée
massive de nouveaux joueurs et on peut
s'attendre dans les années qui viennent
si on refait ce graphique avec les
publications de la fidh et que cette
moyenne lentement aille rejoindre et
bien les nations qui jouent depuis
longtemps cette année en moyenne
tout du moins mille sept cent cinquante
mille huit cents comme la france et
pourquoi pas au-delà
si si c'est possible ça je ne sais pas
voilà alors on va voir encore deux
choses intéressantes
c'est le classement des seuls hommes
donc j'ai enlevé les femmes ici donc
voyez ça ressemble c'est très très
proche ne la courbe général c'est normal
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux
185587 sommes classés avec une moyenne
et l'eau aux alentours de 1900 points et
ça va nous permettre de voir le nombre
de femmes qui jouent donc là on est a
donc quelque chose ici si vous voulez de
90% des hommes classés internationaux et
donc simplement seulement encore que
20000 19 1394 donc environ vingt mille
femmes classées internationaux à
l'international par la fidh et par la
fédération internationale des échecs
c'est-à-dire 10% les joueurs donc elles
sont beaucoup moins nombreuses et donc
forcément aussi on voit là qu'elles sont
aussi récente alors ça se voit de deux
façons 1 parce que le classement étant
comme pour les indiens si vous voulez
nettement décalé sur la gauche est bien
c'est que ce sont donc des joueurs qui
des joueuses pardon qui sont assez
récentes c'est à dire que les filles
jouent depuis peu se met à jouer aux
échecs
ça c'est un premier point l'intégration
de nouvelles joueuses aussi est récent
et puis ça se voit aussi parce que les
regarder les joueuses classées
internationale à partir de 2000
regardez un pic ici non pas vers le bas
comme pour les autres joueurs mais vers
le haut
voilà ce qui signifie que le potentiel
féminin est remarquable voilà parce que
ça veut dire que la courbe logistique
elle est plutôt celle là pour les filles
et que donc leurs moyennes devraient
être supérieures à celles des garçons
c'est dire que quand elles auront
atteint un nombre d'années de jeu
supérieur je parle même pas du nombre
mais c'est un nombre d'années à faire
ici parce que ça c'est des nouvelles
joueuses se piquent là nous fait et
subodoré une moyenne lots pour les
filles qui devrait se retrouver aux
alentours de 1900 points c'est-à-dire
supérieure à celle
des garçons pour un nombre de membres
équivalent alors il faut voir il faut
voir ce que ça va donner mais sur alors
donc à noter quand même que le nombre de
femmes est égal à par exemple la
fédération de russie ou la fédération
d'allemagne tout entière donc les femmes
font presque une nation est la seule
parmi les 160 qui font partie la
fédération internationale d'échecs voilà
en tout cas un gros potentiel pour les
poules et les femmes avec l'arrivée ces
nouvelles joueuses on voit ici
ce pic qui montre bien ici si vous
voulez que et bien les joueuses qui sont
là depuis longtemps un niveau finir
remarquablement supérieur à regarder la
différence ici le nom de joueuses
classées 2 min si le saut vers le haut
c'est la seule cour booth comme ça il ya
un saut vertical et non pas un saut
descendants donc ça veut dire que le
nombre de joueuses qui qui pourrait
potentiellement rejoindre cette courbe
est sans doute très en dessous on est
très en dessous aujourd'hui du potentiel
on devrait avoir un nom je veux bien
plus important dans les années qui
viennent qui vont augmenter le nombre de
femmes qui jouent et donc peut-être
atteindre ce doublé dans les dix ans je
pense que ça serait pas étonnant que
d'ici une dizaine d'années on est au
moins 20% ou 25% de femmes joueuses au
niveau international voilà donc on a
fait le tour voilà on revient sur la
courbe principal avec tous les tous les
joueurs classés on a fait le tour de
ceux de ce classement elo donc on a revu
des moyens de calcul vous pouvez
calculer votre classement pour revoir
cette vidéo en faisant des arrêts aussi
pour essayer de bien comprendre chaque
point et puis on a vu aussi ses
graphiques tout à fait intéressant à
voir et comprendre pour voir comment le
classement elo a un impact comme ça et
peut aussi servir
avec ses graphiques de support d'analysé
pour savoir comment les choses se
passent au niveau international entre
les nations et puis on a vu aussi entre
les grands maîtres et les maîtres et
aussi entre les hommes et les femmes
pour avoir quelques indications
statistiques
grâce à cet outil remarquable donc que
nous a légué le regretté docteur
en mathématiques arpad lots le hongrois
voilà merci de m'avoir suivi sur des
gonades tv pour cette émission spéciale
classement elo et vous donne rendez-vous
à une prochaine émission plus tard sur
des gonades tv au revoir